[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual and amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show he's my
co-host today he talks about jobs and
careers and money and well doing it in a
way that you love it and so if you got
questions about all that you jump in
we'll talk about it and anything else
you want to do we talk about you right
in front of you and we make a living
doing it phone number at 8825 5225 jump
in Marvin is going to start us off this
hour in New York almany to be precise
hey Marvin welcome to the Ramsey
Show um hi Dave and Ken um privilege
um to be able to speaking with you um um
um thank you very much um for all that
you do well thank you how can we
help um so so real brief um I'm 40 um um
my wife is 34 right so we've been
married for 12 years and started a turf
grass Consulting business uh with the
money that we received um from our
wedding right so we do work for um um
local mom and pop golf courses and
conduct um field trials for um plant
protectant
manufacturers uh I was able to go
full-time with the business in
2018 and she was able to go full-time in
2020 um in January thanks to you guys uh
we were able to become debt-free by
paying off our
house um one of our clients will be
selling their Golf Course soon uh so my
question for you is uh should we buy it
for $1.2
million well the first question is can
Dave and I play for
free it could affect our answer no
pressure Mar I'm kidding Mark liftime
membership yeah the uh it's going to
cost you Marvin it's going to cost you
buddy this advice is going to be free
today Dave yeah yeah so uh okay 1.2
million and so this thing is uh has a
net profit after all salaries are paid
including whatever the owner is paying
himself to manage the course because
it's a mom and pop um this thing is
making um 300,000 a
year uh uh no it's doing doing about one
150 to to a 200 net okay so why world
would you pay 1.2 for
that that's overpriced um yeah I I mean
um you know I I I know what know what
know the golf course business fairly
well the uh uh infrastructure in the in
the golf course business um
the the the uh the worth comes from the
assets right to meaning right to golf
carts right maintenance equipment uh
things like that yeah no the worth
doesn't come from that no those things
only have a value to the extent they
create a
profit okay if all of those things
created zero profit you would have
what's known as a
hobby okay not a business and so the
golf carts the infrastructure the
quality of the turf the everything there
the name the reputation in the community
uh the area of town it's in all of that
goes to create one thing profit
and the way you calculate profit is net
profit a a small business is worth a
maximum of five times net
profit five times net profit yeah that's
a 20 that's a 20% rate of return and and
a small business purchase is a very
high-risk purchase and so you would want
at least a 20% rate of return and that's
after that's if you're an absentee owner
and so let's say I bought it for in
Tennessee
okay and I I had to hire a manager and I
had to hire every single staff member
that was needed not you get to work over
there for free or the a former owner
gets to work over there for free and
thereby increase the profits you follow
me real profits for an absentee investor
this is how you calculate the value of a
small business transfer and uh it's
called a cap rate process capitalization
rate um the only other way you could C
calculate the value is the what's called
Book value which would be considerably
less and that is if you took all if you
bought it and you sold off all the
assets you sold off the golf carts you
sold off the real estate you sold off
the uh you collected the receivables you
paid the payables and that's Book value
that should be less than four times five
times net profit it should be okay uh
but that's that's if you were going to
disband the whole operation and it's
worth more sh shut down than it is
operationally then and I I doubt that's
the case here cuz I got to tell you man
I'm I don't know a ton about the golf
business but there's kind of a joke in
the investment world that the guy that
makes the money on a golf course is the
second owner the guy that makes the
money on a ski slope is the second owner
because the first one usually goes
bankrupt there's not much there's not
much margin or spread in that world very
low margins and so um yeah just be
careful not overpay for it if you're
going to pay cash for it Marvin and you
want to buy it it sounds like you know
the golf business at least the side of
it that you've been in but um I'm
telling you the finances on this deal
they don't sound that great um and if
the guy goes well real estate's worth a
lot then he ought to just sell the real
estate if the real estate's worth more
than a million to then he ought to just
sell the real estate put condos on it or
whatever uh cuz I mean from a from a
business transaction standpoint not a
romantic view of grass and trees and
ponds The Real Estate is unquestionably
the most valuable part of this purchase
a mom and pop Golf Course is a mom and
pop Golf Course for a reason not
knocking them I've played some awesome
little munis in my life and they're
great but this is a low margin business
and you probably don't have the
clientele you look at how old your your
average member or your average golfer is
I'd be running all those things Beyond
everything that Dave mentioned and
unless this is a burning
conviction and you got the cash for it
and you can handle it I'd run away from
it unless it's a real estate purchase
only I mean it's just such a low- margin
business you're competing against in
that area you're competing against
higher end clubs that are charging much
much more and you're just limited in
your growth with a small golf course
you're limited your Revenue growth is
limited got to love the way Ken throws
Around The Insider lingo I've played a
lot of really good munis in my time oh
I'm sorry I mean course I should you're
right that was inside baseball inside
golf lingo it just means a local public
course not a private course it's public
anybody can play I've played a lot of
really nice communis in my lifetime that
was pretty good Ken I like the way you
did that that you slipped that right in
there just added to your level of
expertise it was an accident I grew it
wasn't no that's all I could afford to
play my dad we that's all we could play
were munies when I was growing up on a
pastor's
income when I think of munies I think a
municipal bonds Muni bonds oh in the
golf world that just means a I know go
track I figured it out I've figured it
out no it's not necessarily a goat track
there are some nice there are there are
some very nice ones yes I do know what
goat track means it means horrible golf
course yeah I do know I'll tell you a
great one in uh Virginia Beach area
Stumpy Lake there it's a great Municipal
Golf Course great name Stumpy Lake yeah
bunch of tree stumps all over the lake
well-known Muny as of today this useless
information from K Ramy show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus A5 ,000
seller guarantee gives your offer the
best chance of being accepted the home
buyer Edge from Churchill gives you an
advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for being with us
America we appreciate you hanging out
open phones at
5225 our question of the day comes
from neighborly your hub for Home
Services most American homes have dozens
of appliances and chances are at any
given time there's something wrong with
at least one of them Mr Appliance a
neighborly brand offers expert Appliance
iance service on your schedule visit
neighbor.com today to find Home Service
Experts including Mr Appliance in your
area today's question comes from Neil in
Wisconsin I'm wanting to get my degree
in the financial industry what is the
average starting salary for someone who
is straight out of college and what
would their position be how much room
for promotion and growth is in this
industry and how do I set myself up for
Success uh Neil I don't know off the top
of my head what an average starting
salary is because this is kind of a big
ambiguous question in the financial
industry it covers a lot of different
specific you could you could be
everything from bank teller to CEO so
that's a pretty wide range but the
second part of the question we can
address um how much room for promotion
and growth is in this industry well
again depending on the lane that you
pick uh within the financial industry
think of it as a track and field track
there's six eight Lanes there multiple
Lanes of pins you can do very very well
there's no question you could do high
six figures and you could be a seven
figure earner uh in the world of Finance
I mean there's just no question about
that that's everything from Wall Street
to uh an investment professional that
does very very well so uh the sky the
limit uh is the answer to this how do
you set yourself up for Success uh
that's the uh that's the answer the
answer to that is is doesn't matter on
the industry uh I think it is three
parts you got to know your role on every
level that you're at that's Clarity do I
know what's expected of me the second
thing is accept the role win the now
have an attitude of gratitude for where
you are and bust it there is no next if
you don't win the now and third maximize
the role go above and beyond don't walk
around acting like you're the CEO but
then work like you are like you own the
place that's Know Your Role accept your
role maximize your role that's Clarity
attitude and effort I think if you do
that on every level that you're at
you're always going to be promotable
yeah absolutely and and you know
bathe smile show up on time
smile uh don't don't being entitled
twit and um these things will take you a
long way I mean it's because really I
mean in a world of um people who don't
do those basic things you you really do
set yourself apart it's just a big deal
just show up on time you know and um wow
so yeah so Neil the the the the problem
that we're having answering the question
is it's like saying I'm going to get a
marketing degree what do marketing
people make well there's about 8 80,000
different things marketing people do and
the same thing's true with financial a
finance degree I have a finance degree
with a specialization in real estate um
and because I wanted to be in the real
estate business that was my goal I grew
up in the real estate business that was
the long-term thing but I've got all the
financial goober classes under my belt
now and so a thousand years ago I did
and uh um so you know now what are you
going to do with that there's a lot of
different thing you go like Ken said
corporate position as a financial
analyst um and but Finance in general
Finance and Accounting are really good
uh
Baseline uh sets of knowledge to move
into companies and do very well uh for
instance there's two primary sources for
the CEO of major companies in America
today almost all the CEOs in major
companies in America today are either
former CFOs uh or Finance people
accounting people uh Bean counters of
some kind or another or they were the
director of marketing and
sales that's the primary two primary
pools that CEOs come out of the people
that bring in the revenue and the people
that manage and operate the business
well from a numbers perspective
have a higher likelihood of becoming
CEOs uh very few people come from the
graphic arts department to become the
CEO and that's not to put down the
graphic arts department it's just a
statistical fact and so you know you
look at where that's taking you so uh
but yeah it's a great degree as a
baseline of knowledge because in getting
that degree it's a it's a basic Business
Degree you're going to end up with good
statistics under your belt good
accounting under your belt you're going
to end up with Market classes under your
belt and you know those are going to be
those will be knowledge bases that
you'll use wherever you land in business
so all of that sets you up for a
positive situation Carla is in Florida
hey Carla welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for having me so
excited to be talking to you I watch you
all the time on YouTube and I love your
show we appreciate you being here how
can we
help so I have some questions I've been
plowing through
my baby steps and especially paying off
like credit cards
and I I don't have anything saved up in
retirement I'm a nurse I've been a nurse
for 25 years I make
138,000 plus a
year uh my home is paid off my biggest
expense is my car which I owe 23,000 on
and my interest rate is
4.4% so I first I'm going through these
baby steps but I was paying off cards
yesterday so I paid off six cut them up
way to go threw away all the papers so
that I wouldn't be tempted to call them
back for a new
car and now I ran into the next one that
I wanted to pay off and they said if I
pay it off off see this one has an
annual
fee and they said if I paid it off it
was going to ding my credit and that you
know just keep the card and pay the
annual fee but I was like well how much
is that going to ding my credit and does
that matter because that's the next card
to pay off I have five more to pay off
so wait minute let me get this straight
a credit card company told you it's not
a good idea to get rid of a credit card
right no they said keep it
open GNA hurt my credit if I closed it
yeah of course they did yeah well it is
it's going to it is going to damage your
credit score so the question is this
where is it we're trying to get to is is
a credit score your goal or is money
your
goal um retirement is my goal yeah
having and by the way I've had people
try to boil the credit score you can't
eat it
it's worthless you know what a credit
score is good for there's only one thing
a credit score is good for you know what
it
is get more credit borrowing more money
going into debt which is kind of the
opposite of having money for retirement
it's the opposite of what you're trying
to accomplish right now so if your goal
is to get rid of your debt so that you
have some money who cares about your
credit
score yeah and you know I I you drove
right past that you didn't even get
it yes how old are
you I am 60 you are killing it with
138,000 girl I'm proud of you very good
yeah let's get these cars chopped up and
get rid of this car payment and start
piling up some money so five or six
years from now you've got $250 $300,000
set
aside and quit screwing around credit
card if I can if I can pay all my cards
off within the next two months
and then then knock out that $23,000 car
loan in a year and then oh you can do it
faster than that you make 130 you ain't
got anything else to
do this is important well I I do help my
mom and my daughter
out well to the ex how much do you give
them um I pay my mother's car
insurance and my daughter about 500
you're paying an 85y old car
insurance yeah does that seem weird to
you that's scary to me but she's only
living on Social Security yeah I know so
where's the 85-year-old driving
to to church and to the grocery store
yeah thought so this is pretty expensive
trips so um you need to think through
what where your money's going and get
control of it and for sure we don't take
advice from credit card companies on any
anything all we do to them is say
bye-bye see you wouldn't want to be you
you are the cigarette of the financial
world you credit card goobers we don't
want anything to do with you this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to y refi.com
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America I'm Dave Ramsey your host open
phones at
88255 225 Ben is in New York hi Ben
welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you doing great man
what's
up um I am currently living with my
parents I am 29 um I've been saving for
several years now and I'm trying to
figure out if I am ready to uh buy a
house and if I can afford to you know
get my own place at this
point okay how much do you have saved
uh
100K
okay uh what keeps you from leaving
there and buying a
house um well I was mostly just trying
to reach a certain I was trying to reach
that goal of 100 100K save okay you got
100K you got 100K I mean Common Sense
tells me you could go buy a house in
Albany with 100K you're 29 years old how
much do you
make uh about 70 75 cool all right I I I
would definitely do it like this
week you think you think that's a good
idea because I I didn't want to rent
with the thing I didn't want to be
throwing out money you know dude
impulsive is not on your list of things
to do yeah we don't have to worry about
you being impulsive you're 29 you live
at home you're not impulsive okay time
to go yes go get you a house get you a
life yeah for sure no I like it I love
it man so how much do you make again 70
what do you do 70
um I work in
accounting okay you are risk averse
aren't you man you're just hey um it's
time man go out in the sun see the
sunshine the uh the uh the you you are a
numbers dude I love you I'm a nerd I'm a
numbers nerd too man so I'm right there
with you Ben you've been crunching
numbers and crunching numbers and
crunching numbers and the problem with
those numbers nerds is and you're you're
one I'm one so I'm owning it with you we
can get paralysis of the analysis and
and you have a bad
case sure get a house get a life go go
go do something go have some fun man go
you know and and tell your mama you love
her and you'll see her in five months
yeah I mean she going to be she going to
be glad to get rid of you I promise I
don't think she is actually well I think
that's part of the problem he's an easy
guy to live with he's not a problem he's
not let me tell something not like he's
having parties in the basement or
something we're seeing more and more of
this and I'm not picking on Ben but I do
want to say
there's two things that are going on
number one he's got the analysis
paralysis situation yeah but he also
along with the fear of change is how
comfortable he is at Mom's house and
that can just keep you when you because
you can justify
staying by using the numbers and I think
it got to be realistic how much of this
is I'm just afraid to kind of go out and
start adulting that wasn't even a term
10 years ago and I hate saying it I'm a
little embarrassed that I even uttered
it yeah but I mean it's time for a
l a great call back uh but yeah I I just
think we got too many young 20s
somethings that are just terrified of
change and we got to call that up let me
just tell you when you're out there and
on the wire and there's no
net uh it is terrifying yeah it's also
exhilarating and it it it's also what
makes you a man or makes you a woman my
son yeah so yeah um I hey
um you know yes Ben you should go buy a
house and we're not picking on you but
you did open the can of worms so we'll
deal with it for a second um here's the
thing moms and dads you're not doing uh
your kiddos favors when you leave them
in the nest too long a eagle that stays
in the nest too long becomes known as a
turkey and Ben I didn't just call you a
turkey I'm talking about a concept here
okay so Ben you're you're free from this
we're we love you we're happy for you
glad you got 100K you you need to buy a
house in the next month and you need to
move immediately for your sake and it's
good it's good you know we're there but
uh so our our oldest when she came out
of school easy kid oh yeah Denise to
this day she's just a pleasant easy
person and um and she moved back to
she's the only one of them that moved
back to our house after college and uh
she was waiting on a roommate situation
to develop so she could go get the the
first rental property right
and um so she was living there for about
uh two months and we said okay that's
probably enough and she's like what I'm
like you know you you got to you got to
get this done because not because we
don't like it she was not in our way
she's like Ben she could have lived
there and we wouldn't wouldn't have
noticed she' been there until she 29 we
wouldn't have noticed but uh we're like
no you you are missing out on life when
when you're 22 23 25 years old and you
live in your mama's basement you're
missing out on life yeah and so you need
to go be somebody and um it breaks our
heart cuz we love you we we like having
you around but uh it's not about us it's
about you and your development as a
person your uh emotional your
psychological your Spiritual Development
your financial development you become a
different person when you buy your own
eggs and pay your own light bill and
fold your own clothes or don't but
they're your clothes yeah and that it
just changes there's a little thing
happens there little different thing and
again Ben for God's sakes we're not
picking on you okay we're not you called
up you're a nice young man we appreciate
you none of this is aimed at you but I'm
just telling you folks moms and dads you
are stunting their growth 100% reminds
you of that movie with Matthew mccon
Failure to Launch horrible movie I don't
know I think it's a great Matthew
Matthew has done some really good work
in his life and that is not on the list
this is exciting folks Dave ramley with
a strong opinion on a romcom I I I never
thought I'd see the day I mean come if
your co-star is Terry Brad I'm just
saying you're right the quality of the
script writing was low I I'll give you
that but but when Stacey wants to see it
I say okay yeah well yeah there is that
I'm blaming it on her yeah I
would I'm blaming it on you but we're
all right Joe is in Louisville Kentucky
hi Joe what's
up hi thanks for having me guys how are
you better than we deserve how can we
help good um so uh just quick background
last year I had uh I left a job that I
was at for about 15 years uh since then
been struggling to uh you know find a
job uh to make what I need to make to
pay the bills and I'm primarily using
job boards and they just seem to not be
going anywhere that's horrible yeah
resources out there I guess what were
you
making um I was making about 130,000 a
year doing what it was commission so it
kind of went up and down uh sales and uh
management okay and why did you walk out
the door without having anything to go
to uh well they uh had a new ownership
come through and one of the first
changes they made was pay uh for the the
regional manager so I ended up um was on
the pace for about 70k after they uh
took over okay so they cut your pay in
half and you said you said stick it okay
I got that yeah all right so have you
been
working have you been
working yeah I have been working um I'm
currently making um right now about 55k
a year so do you know how to
sell yes I I can sell what were you
selling before when you're making
130 uh it's
furniture wholesale or or customers I
mean or the consumers I'm sorry yeah
customer Uh custom two customers so
retail gotom okay wow I got to tell you
my mom uh sold Furniture was a manager
of a large furniture chain for $35 years
and if you can make that kind of money
in Furniture those margins aren't that
high uh you've got a lot of options in
front of you right now a lot and you've
got to stop job boarding and you've got
to start start having coffee with people
that you know Civic clubs churches you
know people and look you can sell
anything you're not a guy who's stuck in
an industry in other words you aren't
just effective in the furniture industry
you know a product you know a service
not only can you sell it Joe but you let
a team of people medical medical device
sales you can make two and a quarter
easy
easy so with i' I've looked at some
medical like sales jobs I just feel like
um you know I I don't feel like it's you
know qualified I guess for it do you you
just apply anyways there aren't doctors
making the sales there sales people Mak
sales to doctor yeah I got a friend
who's got who's a former college
football player I'm not knocking
football players he's ad advising
surgeons on Orthopedic devices in the
operating room not cuz he's a genius
because they trained him on the devices
Dave's right you don't need anything
other than a willingness to learn and
basic intelligence and you have both of
those in droves hey we're going to send
you Ken's book from paycheck to purpose
I want you to go on his website and
learn his oh oh no also we're going to
send you proximity principle his other
number one cuz that's that does that's
what you do instead of job boards what
it'll help you do what you're supposed
to do yeah
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other
that's why there's netsuite by Oracle in
the early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
open phones atle
8825 5225 Ken Coleman Ramsey
personalities my co-host Evan is in
Indianapolis hi Evan how are you good
how are you better than deserve what's
up um so I'm a young guy last couple
years um I'm a I'm a numbers cruncher
and my numbers aren't crunching anymore
and I'm not able to build my
savings and I'm not sure what to do with
it okay what do you
make uh I make 2750 an hour okay and uh
so what is that about 70 a year
um it's more like 60 a year isn't it
yeah yeah okay what do you
do uh I'm an a mechanic so I work on
Farm Equipment okay all right and um how
much debt do you
have about
117,000 on
what uh 75 on my house I got 27,000 in
student
loans and 16 on a car
okay all right are you
single uh no getting ready to get
married in a month what's she
make uh she's part-time because we had
this is where the whole two-year thing
came in uh we had a kid two years
ago um and she so she makes I think she
makes 15 an hour and she works 20 to 25
hours a
week okay all right well there's there's
two sides of the equation the income
side and the outgo
side and if we want to uh change the
numbers we usually end up working on
both so you're working 40 hours she's
working 15 somebody going to be working
more if we want more money or we're
going to be working differently meaning
a new career if we want more money and
um and that the outgo side is a car
payment and a student loan payment when
you get rid of those by tearing into
them and making the major priority a
priority above all other things and get
rid of them uh then you know you can get
there but if you guys are making 100,000
between the two of you or 880,000
between the two of you you can work
through a $166,000 car debt and a
$27,000 student loan debt you know in 18
24 months but you're going to be on
beans and rice rice and beans you're
going to be working overtime and you're
going to sell so much stuff the dog
thinks it's
next are you
budgeting uh I mean I kind of do I mean
I don't have have any no is the answer I
don't have yeah no okay yeah and I'm not
that's not a setup question but when
somebody says I can't seem to get caught
up I can't seem to pile up savings we
have baby steps anyway so we want you
$1,000 baby step one that's for
emergencies then you're attacking this
debt but you've got to know where your
money is going and if you're not
budgeting you're going to have a hard
time getting traction whether you're in
baby step one getting $1,000 baby step
two knocking that debt off baby step
three saving up 3 to six months
emergency fund if you're not budgeting
you have a greater chance of spinning
your wheels because you just simply
don't know where the money's going so so
when are you getting
married uh October the 7th awesome hey
we're going to give you a wedding gift
uh oh I'm going to put you and the bride
through Financial Peace University both
of you have to go if I give it to you
for free do you promise yes I promise
nine lessons it also includes UD the
world's best budgeting app every dollar
the premium version which connects to
your bank and I want you to jump in that
immediately and start using it today I'm
going to give it to you right now
Austin's going to pick up and tie you
into it but get on the every dollar app
like Ken was saying because here's what
we find research has shown across the
general population that when people
start doing a written budget each month
they have a 10 to a 15% lift in their
money because there's that much in Lost
in just disorganization and impulse
spending uh we find it's actually more
than that because the people we're
dealing with are different than the
general public the people we're dealing
with are like you Evan they're sick and
tired of being sick and tired and
they're about ready to bust into
something and so they lean in even
harder on that budget and they make
every one of those dollars
squeal they make every one of those
dollars behave and that's why we even
call the budget every dollar every
dollar has an assignment and that's why
the budgeting app is called that every
dollar has a name every dollar has an
assignment and so you're just going to
get
um uh merciless on making the money that
the two of you have coming in behave and
squeeze every dime out of it increase
your income decrease your outgo and then
walk these baby steps and financial P
University will help you do that and uh
certainly the every dollar budgeting app
will help you do that so check those out
we're going to give them to you free as
a wedding gift and get you started
because I've been right where you are
Evan when people say Ken Ken caught that
beautifully because I used to say that
too I can't seem to get and what that
usually means is I haven't been able to
out earn my disorganization I haven't
been able to out earn my stupidity I
haven't been able to out earn my impulse
spending I haven't been able to out earn
my lack of a plan and nobody can by the
way and I used to think I'd just go get
more money because I'm an abundance guy
and I would go get more money and then I
would screw it up you know and so you
know you've got to make the money that
you have behave and when you're managing
that well you become what's called a
faithful Steward someone who is
stewarding their money in a trustworthy
Manner and God looks down and goes oh
wait there's one in Indianapolis that
gets it yeah ha who knew you know and uh
we might be able to let him manage some
more that's right if he's managing what
he has well y hello that's a basic
biblical principle and last piece of
encouragement Evan if you budget first
dive into every dollar start to see
where the money is you'll be more
motivated to do extra work because as an
a mechanic who can work on those big old
machines that I don't even know how they
work right he can work on a lot of
different engines he's got some
transferable skills there's a lot of
side work where you as a mechanic can
make really good money but you're more
motivated to do that when you go okay
now I'm actually getting ahead mhm
because I'm now disciplined and I have a
plan yeah and where do I want to be in
10 years right so now you're going okay
I'll go bust it yeah and where do I want
to be in my career in 10 years yeah that
that's a plan this is how it works boys
and girls beautiful hey Austin will pick
up and get you signed up we'll get you
taken care of Susan's in New York hey
Susan welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you better than I
deserve what's
up I have a question um I'm currently in
a condo that I want to sell and I'm
looking at either renting it out and
then buying something new um or maybe
selling it and kind of taking this like
windfall as we want to call it that
that's going on in real estate and pay
off my debt and then also buy something
new B either way I feel like I want to
leave this condo but I'm afraid to let
it go because I a good interest rate on
it like it's called a windfall you you
nailed it You Gonna Take the Money and
Run let it go let it go oh my God how
about that Dave you didn't see that
coming no you're right was on Key by I
hope I never see it coming again Jade
did the exact same thing yesterday but
it was a little better well Jade is a
lot better than me let's call out no so
anyway yeah Susan we've been interrupted
here by a solo that was uninvited made
so the deal is this um we yeah you don't
want to keep the condo because you're
becoming a landlord by
default not by intent if you own another
house and you were debt-free and you had
a pile them you know and you wouldn't go
borrow on that house in order to buy a
condo in the city you just wouldn't do
it and effectively by not selling this
it's the same thing as if you bought
it you know in terms of a balance sheet
or in terms of the decision-making
Paradigm and so yeah you're much better
off to I can't even say it let it youed
you went there you caught yourself yeah
it's just got to chill but yeah let it
go yeah that's what you need to do and
you're GNA be humming that around the
house tonight and Sharon's gonna be like
what are you doing you're gonna be like
Coleman who are you what that's all you
need to say she'll understand K
Coleman's fault she'll understand so
many things are but hey you've taught
this for years the idea of being a a
distance and or even or even local it
creates headaches yeah just you know yes
real estate's a good investment but very
few people back into it you need to walk
into it with cash after you got the rest
of your finances straightened out so
sell it Susan sell it please that's what
I would do if I woke up in your shoes
and thank you for the call this is the
Ramy
[Music]
show
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsey Network wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
Ken Coleman ramsy personality host of
the Ken Coleman show and author of the
number one bestselling book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host as we
talk about your job your life your money
money your where your money comes from
your work Ken is an expert in that area
and he can help so jump in the phone
number is 8825
5225 Jim is with us in Vancouver hi Jim
welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up um I'm calling from just
outside Vancouver in British Columbia
here and basically I was wondering if it
was smarter for me to buy a house or
start start a business first and if you
would think buying a house would be
smarter how would I go about that with
today's like housing market buying a
house in terms of to live in as your
home or as a rental
property it would be to live in as my
own ideally with a sweet torrento but
that might be further down the line okay
are you
single I'm single yeah what do you
make um I'm 20 and I still do live with
my parents but I currently make 35 bucks
an hour what's the business you want to
start um it would be in the um equipment
services and Welding um
industry okay I I obviously you know how
to uh do equipment services and Welding
uh where are you going to get your
customers uh so I got quite a few
connections from past jobs at farms and
whatnot from when I was a bit younger so
I would be able to get a lot of
customers in the agricultural um type of
work is that business gonna require go
ahead go ahead well what I'm getting at
is he said house or start business and
so I'm wondering is there a lot of
capital outlay like are you going to
have to put a lot of money into this to
launch this business
idea um so I again I haven't really put
a whole lot of thought like I get I've
put a lot of thought towards starting
the buiness business but I haven't
really tallied up the numbers because um
I've just been told that for buying a
house if you're selfemployed the bank
doesn't look super highly on that rather
than if you make a steady income at a
place that's been around for a lot
longer they're going to want to see two
in America they're going to want to see
two tax two years of tax returns I don't
know what it is in British Columbia but
two years of tax returns as a
self-employed person proves you make
money other than that there's no problem
at all being self-employed but uh but
obviously you can't move in there with
uh and again I do not know the mortgage
process in uh British Columbia I can't
comment on that I'm ignorant about it so
but you'd have to find that out but I
think you're probably you know you're on
the right track there with that issue um
how much money do you have
saved um so I currently have 35,000 in
my savings and then I got just under
30,000
invested okay good for you all right and
um you you are in the welding and uh
equipment Services business now making
$35 an
hour that's correct okay and so are do
you have the ability to do side jobs in
the same industry without uh stepping on
your current employer customers or
stealing from them in any
way yes that's that's the other thing
that I said Sor in my email earlier I
never men breaking up I didn't
understand you try
again um I do have the ability to work
on side jobs from home and also from the
shop without getting in the way of my
current career yeah without ethics
problems with your current employer
right exactly okay all right so what I
would do is uh I would not start my
business full-time I would start it
parttime and and start doing some side
gigs and I would go get me a rental prop
a place to rent and just you know move
out of your parents house you're 20
years old um and I would not buy a house
right now I would just keep piling up
cash you got plenty of time there's
nothing to do with the housing market
it's got to do with where you are and
then I want you to build up that side
gig build up that side gig to where
you're making more with it than you are
during your day job then you're ready to
quit and run your job run your business
fulltime the big deal here that you're
going to discover Jim and I want you to
discover this by actually doing it not
not in theory not discussing it uh what
you're going to discover is is that
doing the welding and being an excellent
welder is a different skill set than
running a
business yeah you can be an excellent
technician and still run the business
poorly you could be you can run a
business well and be a horrible
technician people do that sometimes but
uh what often happens is someone is a
great chef and so they automatically
assume they need a
restaurant well it's a completely
different thing to run a restaurant than
it is to be a chef the only thing that's
in common is food that's the only thing
I mean Chef is one skill operating a
business is another skill and that
that's what I'm seeing with you so I I
think you're probably very good at what
you do you sound very competent and
confident and um so I would want you to
to just build this up on the side what
do you think yeah the only thing got to
add to that is while you're doing the
work on the side see there's no risk
here you're not Allin you got a great
job no conflict of interest and now I'm
learning the business with zero risk and
Dave's right there's a process of
welding then there's I'm selling these
parts and that's a whole different ball
game then I'm running my business and
while I'm doing it on the side I'm
learning by experience but I'm also
going to sit with people who are winning
in the industry I will tell you this
Dave I think the most underrated
question in the history of the world is
will you help me and will you help me in
this case a young man who's 20 who
approaches a guy maybe in his 30s or 40s
or 50s or 60s and says hey I want to get
into this business one day can I buy
your lunch or coffee and will you just
tell me what I need to know you helping
me is you just giving me some knowledge
and some wisdom and I have found that
successful people are very willing to
help that person who asked that question
and shows up with a willingness to learn
pad and paper notes on your phone I
don't care how you do it and if you do
that here's what happens now you get all
this wisdom and knowledge from somebody
who's been way out in front of you and
then you begin to apply it on the side
and Dave's right that picks right back
up where Dave's advice is at some point
you're going to scale it to the point
where you can walk away from the day job
right into working for yourself but
there's no risk here and patience is the
key it's hard to be patient when you're
20 I mean crap it's hard for me to be
patient at 49 but it's really hard to be
patient when you're 20 but patience is
what sets you up for the Long Haul and I
think that's the that's the only thing
I'd add to what you said I thought the
advice was fantastic so don't buy a
house no move out don't start your
business full-time start it part-time
build it up build it up build it up
build it up learn the business skills
and I'll send you a copy of our number
one bestselling book entree leadership
great which is how we show people what
our Playbook has been on running a
business how we grew the ramsy solutions
business from a card table in my living
room to now almost 1,00 folks on the
team and over 300 million a year in
revenue and we'll show you how we did
that and so but that's the skill set
it's a different set of skills than
welding and you you got to be good at
both to make this work this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host thanks for being here America
open phones at
5225 you jump in and we will talk Joe is
in Lake Charles Louisiana hi Joe welcome
to the Ramsey
Show yes sir thank you all for taking my
call sure what's up so my question today
is um an
a couple at our church is offering to
owner finance their house to us and I'm
just calling to see if that is going to
be a smart play with my current
situation okay um well we T you know we
can check your current situation so how
much debt do you
have um right now we're on baby step two
we still have about 40
42,000 um m which ranges from a credit
card car note what's your household
income um 65 to 70,000 so when do you
plan to do be done with the
42 um we're we're snowballing I mean by
two two and a half three years okay
would be yeah that sounds reasonable um
we tell folks Joe not to buy a home
while they're in
debt okay because uh um you know Murphy
will move in your spare bedroom and the
water heater will break the roof will
leak and the heat and air will go out
and you're broke because you're still in
debt and then you got a real mess on
your hands so what appears to be a
blessing because of the timing is not
going to be a blessing it would end up
being a curse so I would tell you to
wait and that may mean that this couple
sells the house to someone else and
that's fine and you'll you know God will
have something else for you there'll be
another plan when you're ready and you
have a good emergency fund and a good
down payment and you have no debt and
you move into a house in that situation
the house can be a blessing not a curse
but when you move into a house broke you
just get broker that's why they call
them Brokers you know just it's a bad
idea don't do it don't do it James is
that
ready yeah okay all right so uh they
sent me this thing God K this I don't
know if you saw this or not I haven't
seen this this is very exciting little
bit it's not exciting it's scary it's
not okay it's scary so I mean we get
scamed stuff all the time people using
my name you know people using you know
saying Dave Ramsey said do this Dave
Ramsey said do that and it's like well
of course stve Ramsey didn't say to do
that that's dumb he wouldn't do that
that's and you know anybody that knows
us know these things but then people
that don't know us they think I'm
endorsing you know bull crap so this one
pops up this one's scary because it's AI
That's what I was going to ask you yeah
so you going to play it play it this is
on Instagram this is the dumbest thing
I've seen I don't know when to credit
card debt surged to
$1.03 trillion it marks the highest
level ever on record that part in the
FED dating back all the way to 2003 um I
have about $116,000 worth worth of debt
um and includes a car a credit card the
medical debt from the birth of our son
okay so what you need to do and this
applies to my listeners at home who have
debt is go apply for an economic
recovery package today do you hear me
yes sir fastest way is to settle it and
pay pennies on the dollar for what you
owe and you can do that using a free
service through the economic recovery
program today thank you sir wow hey we
love you you hold on a second Kelly's
going to pick up okay the economic
recovery package and pay pennies on the
dollar and you of course you swipe down
and you go to this website to buy their
crap and uh and obviously I mean I was
said AI when I first heard it on my
computer it was AI but when I heard it
now just now in the studio that doesn't
it's not even AI it's just a bad voice
yeah he got
phrase he got one little phrase that was
close but to somebody who doesn't listen
to you much and did a driveby on YouTube
that's nasty that is really bad it was
an Instagram thing so we of course we
got the attorneys on it where we get
them shut down Instagram shut them down
but uh then they pop back up as quick as
you shut them down because it's you know
it's scam every quack yeah it's they're
everywhere but I I they just you know
you don't notice but it would changed
from these earbuds in our ears to the
microphone with in front of our face
exactly and uh and then the thing in
front of your face it makes it look like
I'm saying it and uh and then closes out
with with me actually closing the call
out of course you know the ultimate
deception bookend it with actual real
stuff from you it's very you know that
that freaks me out all fraudulently and
in violation of copyright by the way too
but yeah wow wow so no we do not endorse
the economic Recovery Act which doesn't
even
exist which by the way yeah what a joke
does not EX exist there's no such thing
economic recovery and so and you can
settle your debts for pennies on the
dollar yeah you can do that but what
this is is one of these scam uh debt
consolidation places yes and they're
getting you into a debt consolidation
process and oh my God but that part was
brilliant because that's the kind of Foo
that we hear from DC they say things
like economic Recovery Act and we all go
oh they're here to help yeah economic
yeah yeah you're right that that's it's
troubling though it's troubling Ronald
Reagan had a famous quote he said the
most scary words in the English language
are I'm from the government and I'm here
to help yep that's exactly right amen
and amen the economic Recovery Act and
just just what does that even mean yeah
it's not even an act by the way oh it is
an act but it's not that kind of an act
yeah wow wow crazy stuff if you're going
to try to rip your voice off practice a
little better than that come on man
sound like I was from
California not enough Tennesse in that
no twang in that Doug is in Grand Rapids
hey Doug what's
up hey Dave and Ken how are you guys
doing today better than we deserve
what's up hey excellent I'm glad I'm
speaking to you guys I've been listening
to the show for about six years now and
a little bit embarrassing to state that
my wife and I are not completely out of
debt yet because we're what I like to
say and I hear you say on the show all
the time we're sort of
ramish um we did successfully pay off
$888,000 of student loans
um huge weight it lifted off the
shoulders and with all the student loan
speak going on right now it's amazing to
not have to deal with that um but my
question today has to do with Roth IRAs
because we still have $62,000 in debt um
on three line items two of them are cars
and one is a camper um how much do you
owe on a camper camper we ow
24,000 okay so onethird of this is a
camper okay yep and the other 40 or
38,000 is broken into how many what kind
of car how much we have a 27 on the
Tahoe and nine or almost 10,000 on an
edge okay all right so you have a car
and a camper problem okay yep um now
what's your household income we bring in
Gross about 160 a year so we're only at
about 41% of our annual income were a
little bit below the 50% that you teach
okay and so and you want to pull out
your WTH
well the question is because I've
actually listened to the show for six
years and I've never heard this question
so I may have a good one um and I know
you teach not to pull from retirement
because of the penalties and taxes
associated with doing that but in our
case we each my wife and I each have a
Roth IRA in my name I have a Roth of
$10,000 um and she's got 5,000 in her
name and my question was about the cash
equivalent because obviously after tax
absolutely not this is not a Roth
problem or a tax problem or a penalty
problem this is a Doug problem mhm Doug
really Behavior you make 160 Grand and
you owe money on a
camper yeah come on well we do and you
want to cash out your freaking
retirement for a
camper no we also rent that out
through yeah no Dave I'm in the camper
investment business no you're
not yeah you know better than that dude
what's it worth you have any idea it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
gone yeah that's what I'm getting it's
gone it's depreciating either you pay
these cars and these campers off in the
next 18 months out of your cash flow and
you guys quit being is or you know the
the cuz here's the problem you keep
treating the
symptom and you know when you take this
money out of retirement
and start with it's not enough to do
spit it's not enough money in there but
if if you did take it out you keep
treating the symptom and the symptom is
the debt the problem is the
Doug the douie okay so so you got to got
you guys are going to have to quit being
is that's what we're saying you're going
to have to get on a decent plan get on
get on every dollar you and your wife
sit down and go okay we knocked out
88,000 now we look kind of foolish
sitting here with these debts making 160
Grand we make too much money money to be
this freaking broke you have no money in
retirement Doug I mean you have $5,000
that's pitiful it's pitiful and you make
$160,000 a year come on man this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion doar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and and you can join at any
time so find out more at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions we have a thing called the
debt-free stage we also have an a
viewing area where you can come in get
free homemade chocolate chip cookies and
coffee come by and visit us if you're in
town from Boise Idaho or something like
that so we got a group of uh ladies
sitting here on the front row we just
met them at the break from boisey so hey
people come from All Over America and
visit Nashville and sometimes we're one
of the places they stop and see we do
this the show on the glass from 1 to 4:
every day central time and if you come
and watch you'll agree that it's pretty
much like watching ugly paint dry but
there you go so hey I don't resemble
that he hey watch out what's happening
hey but also we have the debt free stage
in that Lobby and that's where Mike and
Lindsay are hey guys how are you hi hi
good welcome where do you guys live St
Louis Missouri there we go awesome and
how much debt have you paid off uh
360,000 yo how how long did that take
about 32 months good for you and your
range of income during that time uh
120,000 to
350,000 okay in three years you double
your over double your income we did
almost triple it y wow what do youall do
for a living uh I am a internal medicine
doctor ah there we go and I work in the
financial services industry well that's
vague enough good okay all right
excellent so now you yeah so that's a
way to double or triple your income the
two of you excellent very good so uh
goodness what kind of debt was the 360
uh mostly student loans about 346,000
with student loans and the rest says the
doc yeah the rest was an investment loan
and a car loan okay wow very cool how
long you been out med school uh about
well out of medical school no I mean out
out of residency and everything about
three years about three years so about
this time yep so you got out and you
said let's knock it out correct game on
yep all right so what how did you get
connected to this Ramsey stuff what made
y'all do this yeah so um we were
probably Dave is I had heard about the
Dave Ramsey Show before Lindy and I got
married which was six years ago and we
were on our honeymoon and uh being the
financial guy I was uh listening to the
Dave Ramsey Show podcast wow uh and then
Lindsay uh being like I think she was
reading a book and she said what are you
doing what are you listening to and it
was uh the Dave Ramsey show we listened
to the podcast uh and that's how we got
first connected and then uh my family
gifted us uh FPU for Christmas as well
okay and so then when she comes out of
med school no question how what we're
gonna do correct we're GNA knock this
out pop done done done done very good
Lindsay I got to ask you as the doctor
in your world did you share the process
the journey as you were doing it and if
you did uh what did you find the
reaction was and and I'm just curious
how many other people that are in your
shoes to the doctors that are actually
even thinking about getting after it the
way you all did uh yeah I mean we talk
pretty openly about it um and honestly
most of the people are not doing what we
did uh a lot of the people are doing
Public service loan
forgiveness um or they just kind of are
on the you know 10 20 year plan they'll
eventually pay it off you know they make
enough money um they want like the big
expensive house or the fancy car and all
that stuff doc iish correct did they
look at you treat you like incredulously
like what are you thinking no never that
type of situation just more so could
tell that they didn't necessarily agree
with it right like that would be nothing
that they would ever do yeah yeah but
look at you yeah look at you I'm
completely free 32 months that's Rowdy
wow that is very cool what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
cuz you're successful at it um I would
say my key is uh the budget and then
also we we always had like really
short-term goals but then also having
the longer term goals we were always
having goals that we wanted to get done
within like you know a month or two and
then also what's our goal 5 to 10 years
from now like what do we want life to
look like so that's really what kept me
going yeah I I would say like
consistency so like we knew how much
money was going towards debt and we set
that goal from the beginning and just
kept on going um and also um you guys
have heard the phrase or used the phrase
dream dates um that was that was huge
for us like keep us motivated keep us
going um look to the Future uh and what
Legacy we want to leave behind yeah you
got to have a vision absolutely for your
life correct and uh when you have a
shared dream then that's the living like
no one else so that later we get to live
and give like no one else and that you
got to have that later you know in sight
in high definition and be able to tell
what's really going on with it way to go
you guys way to go I'm curious I I I
know if don't know if I've ever asked
anybody this question but you're a
financial guy and you're in that world
and so you're Pro probably academically
trained like I was uh the same way uh
because there's probably uh I don't know
two or 3 hundred podcasts and radio
shows on money out there oh why why what
what was it that a financial guy goes
well this is okay I can listen to this
yeah I think for me it was
honestly before getting married to
Lindsay I didn't know debt or have debt
um and I knew just threw you under the
bus I brought all the debt and backed
over I did have an investment in a small
car but
uh but I think the biggest thing is we
uh knew before marriage that we wanted
to tackle the debt and with Co and no
interest we wanted to get it out of our
lives for good I mean why this why why
were you listening to this show Dave
it's because of your personality oh my
God uh you let me scoot over so his head
can fit in here hold on you and
I uh no I just really liked uh the
principles the baby steps uh now we're
on four five and sixense clear path the
clear path made sense yeah okay that
that I'll
buy way to go you guys we're very proud
of you congratulations thank you he and
uh also you've had a baby yes all right
and brought did you brought him with you
right we did he's four now no longer a
baby yeah that's right wow very cool
very cool so six years married
four-year-old and 32 months a after med
school boom this is gone hey we got a
copy of the uh baby steps millionaires
book for you in the live and give box
and the B The Total Money Makeover book
and a Financial Peace University
membership probably got all those
already but you can give them away and
somebody who wants them and so what's
the four-year-old's name Christopher all
right Christopher here we go man ready
your mom and dad have changed your life
buddy you don't even know how much yet
you have a family tree that has been
changed by by two Heroes right here
$360,000 paid off in 32 months making
120 to 350 Mike Lindsay and Christopher
from St Louis count it down let's hear a
debt free Scream 3 2 1
we're debt
free
[Applause]
yeah that is how it's done you got to
love it so Ken there is an antidote to
the student loan crisis and uh we just
observed it yeah there human beings
taking responsibility because the
private student loan forgiveness that
she said some of these docs are counting
on has a
1.6 per success rate
98.4% of the people that apply for that
do not get
it that's all of
them so these docs have screwed up by
betting their their Futures on the
private student loan forgiveness public
student loan forgiveness act it's it
doesn't work it's a another time your
government has lied to you and so we're
going to be having this coming Tuesday
night Jade washaw Rachel Cruz me are
going to be doing a free live stream for
a couple hundred thousand of you that
are going to be viewing it's at 700 p.m.
central Time this coming Tuesday night
student loan debt in America how we got
here and how we're going to get out
we're going to show you some real
solutions this is ramsy Solutions that's
what we're here for and we're not here
for something that's going to if if
you're looking for easy I I don't I
can't help you with easy if you're
looking for microwave quick I can't help
you with that we sell crockpots baby 32
months they've been scratching and
clawing those folk 32 months they went
through Financial Peace University they
listened to the podcast they've read the
books
32 months of nothing and now they're
free
$360,000 in debt
wow yeah go to Ramsey solutions.com
studentloans to sign up for Tuesday
night this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Joe's with us in Houston
Texas hi Joe how are you pretty good uh
so my question today Dave and uh Ken is
U I work for an automation supplier
company for the oil and gas industry
I've been here for almost a year my
responsibilities have increased uh a lot
more than I thought they would and I
would like to bring up uh getting a
raise to uh to my leadership and stuff
like that and kind of wanted to know
about how to go about doing that how
much have you got a number in your mind
a percentage that you've done some
research on or is this just a hunch and
a
feeling uh so so I'm I'm definitely
making less than what I was previously
with the job I left in you know uh where
we were maintenancing the solutions that
were uh being sold by by different
companies and now I'm designing and
implementing those uh so I took a pay
cut to come to this job for more
freedoms more responsibilities and
chances to grow and the number I've got
is about 12 to 15% is what you want as a
race yes and you've been there a year
have you had an annual review or is that
process in place
uh so I had a six-month review and
everything was everything with that was
was gold stars and from what I was told
so when did The increased
responsibilities get put on you give me
a
timeline at the six-month Mark and and
you were told this it like hey here's
what we're doing you're doing a great
job gold stars now we're GNA add this
this this and this is that how it went
yes did you bring up okay hey I'm glad
for the review uh is there an increase
in comp what's that look like my measure
did you bring that up at the time so I
brought that up at the time and the
company I work for is
growing and uh so they were like okay
we're going to push off your raise until
so then I asked for a
6% they said we're going to push it off
till October well then the
responsibilities that was It was
supposed to increase it's gone beyond
that in the in the six
months because we're we're developing a
new a new department for for our branch
and I've been kind of given that okay
and that's now
you I make 825 okay and so you're asking
for like 10
grand yeah okay all right and they're
supposed to review it in October anyway
so just a few weeks yes yes sir okay all
right all right I'd Hold the Line I'd
hold the line on the number if and again
Dave I I want you in the it's all it's
all The Narrative of how you couch it
okay so just the the best way to do a
lot of these things especially in
business is just trade shoes for a
minute M okay if you're the leader
you're the owner you're the manager of
that's making these decisions okay how
would you want to
be uh addressed how would you want this
conversation to sound and and I'm an
owner of a company I'll tell you how I
want it to sound um I'm happy to talk to
anybody about their comp uh I'm happy
for them to talk to leadership here
anytime about their comp uh and and you
know here's the thing you're not
entitled to
anything you earn it and you have said
you're earning it but I mean I had one
guy come in my office Joe a few years
ago and he's like well I've got this
degree and that degree the poor guy had
more degrees than a thermometer and he
he said you know people that have
degrees like me at other places you know
they make uh $50,000 more a year than
I'm paying and I said yeah then you're
they're paying me I said I understand
that but we don't pay for degrees here
this is a small business honey your
raise is effective when you
are okay and so that's what the owner is
looking for your raise is effective when
you are you've made the case to me
listening to you that you've been
effective and you've gotten the
increased responsibility and you're
stepping up and you're taking emotional
ownership of these areas and so you're a
valuable team member is what it sounds
like to me and so but the way you want
to couch it if you're on the other side
of the desk is how Joe I mean think
about it you want to say uh not I
deserve ve more money simply go I think
I'm adding a lot of value do you think
I'm adding a lot of value if I'm adding
value I need to ask you how do I go
about talking to you guys in a proper
way without sounding ungrateful because
I'm very grateful I love this place I
love the opportunity I love the growth I
love the added responsibility um and I
you know what's the right way if you're
me to ask you guys about compensation
and I I I'd really like to make more and
what do I need to is there anything I'm
not doing that I'm that I'm do you know
is there anything I can add or is there
do I need to do something different to
qualify for some increased compensation
and if somebody says to me how can I
what can I do to make myself more
valuable so you want to give me more
money that's an easy that's an easy
thing for me as an owner I can do that
one okay I can go okay because you know
like I had a guy one time he was working
on a deal and he brought in an extra
million dollars that really happened
that blew my mind he he just he added
this thing to a deal he was doing
negotiating a deal for us and he added
this thing and and so and his commission
structure did not pay him on that
million dollars but you know what we
paid him anyway you know why cuz I want
him to do that
again I got you okay cuz he added value
you see what I'm talking about so a lot
of value in that case that's a big
number but the the thing is here I I
think you say I am I I think I'm adding
value am I adding value and if I'm not
adding enough what do I need to be doing
to qualify for increased compensation
because I really want to be one of your
best team members and I also want to
make some good money and tell me how to
do that man yeah I agree with that
however I would also add to this Joe
they promised you a 6% I I I would
ignore that because I think he's do I
think he's do a lot more than six 6% a
joke in this yeah maybe he needs he
needs he needs have some Marketplace
research on that like if somebody comes
to us and says yeah but he's he's on a
startup and they're they're adding stuff
they're adding new products they're
adding new projects and things to his
plate left and right left and right he
and he's making 80 already he's he's
worth another 10 I think he is but he's
got to make that case and I'm just
pointing out that he's going in asking
for 12 to 15 they've asked six he needs
to show Market ranges I wouldn't ask for
1215 I would I ask open-ended question
okay cuz he was saying he we had talked
about six back in the summer feel like
I'm doing all these things what have I
got to do yeah oh I I always say that
too and you know that kind of thing and
and then if they come back at six You'
go okay I need to know what I got to do
to get double that CU I kind of thought
I was in that zone and apparently I'm
not so and they've added
responsibilities so if you talk to me
that way and you don't you know start
trying to but let me soon as somebody
starts playing hard ball with us at
Ramsey on uh Ray negotiation right we
just go you know it's probably not going
to work out here right cuz we're not
going to you know you're going to
negotiate come on I mean ask how you can
help yeah and if you kill it and drag it
in here we'll share it with you baby
yeah I mean it's not we're not greedy
but but you know just I show up every
day and breathe and so I get money
that's not what Joe's doing right but if
you if you're out there and you think
well I just show up every day and I'm
you know actually took a shower daily
and I expect a raise I mean come on man
there's no just shower daily race that's
there's not one of those so um you know
it's crazy what's out there and the way
people think about this stuff so you
know here's the thing if you want to be
an extremely valuable team member always
be asking what you how you can add value
how I can lift the place not what I can
take from it so if we're interviewing
someone and the first two sentences all
they want to knows what they
get then we're done with the interview
cuz they're there to take they're not
there there to add they're going to work
at J O work as little as possible come
in late leave early and steal while
they're there and so you want to present
that the exact opposite of that scenario
age when you're uh interviewing or when
you're negotiating so to speak for a
raise but it's not negotiating it's
asking leading questions yes and also
being informed in what you're asking we
come the other day in in one of our
technology roles a very unusual Niche
role but he said I got to I got to
recruiter coming at me offering me X
more and he goes I don't want to leave
it's crazy amount of money he goes what
should I do and and that's a way to
approach it not like if you don't match
this guy I'm out of here right cuz we'd
be going see you wouldn't want to be you
you know that's right and um but but if
he comes in and goes that you know what
we we were not able to match it but he
wanted to stay we were able to respond
to his situation and make him feel good
about staying by giving him a great race
yeah and it was it was an unscheduled
raise hello so that's okay all that's
fine but this is a how you the attitude
you approach it are you a giver or are
you a taker are you a parasite or are
you someone that's adding to the whole
process and if you're adding to the
process and the people don't respect
that with your in your wallet you
probably need to look for another place
Joe I think you got a good situation and
you're a good guy this is going to work
out for you this is the Ramsey
Show hey it's Ken if you love The show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the ramsy way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
America Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author of the
book paycheck to purpose is my co-host
he hosts also the Ken Coleman show on
Series XM as a podcast here on the
Ramsey networks and uh very popular
answering your questions about jobs and
work and career and uh you can find him
every day doing that and of course be
sure and check in with us here today
he'll help you too the phone number8
825-5222 expenses are covered so like if
I put everything extra towards the house
I could pay it off in six years which
sounds great but my parents prioritize
paying off their house before retirement
so now they don't really have
retirement okay how old are you I'm 33
Okay so if you did that you'd be 39
years
old exactly so mathematically you would
not be your
parents because you definitely could
save a lot for retirement if you no
house payment between now and retirement
between 39 and 65 right that's a good
point okay yeah so your parents your
parents the fear that came from your
parent situation is not valid in your
case however I'm still not going to tell
you to do that but I just think it's
good to work out the math for a second
now um so you're out of debt everything
but the house right correct and you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses set aside
correct right I have 15
good okay then you're at what we call
baby step four baby step four is say 15%
of your income no more into retirement
if you have no payments but a house
payment 15% of your income going into
retirement should leave you some money
in your
budget and about 500 if I do that what's
your household
income 77,000 pre-tax post tax amends it
being about
57 and how much is your house payment
it is let's see I wrote that down where
did I go
um
1,330 okay how are you paying off your
house in six years if you save nothing I
don't hear that in these
numbers I have an extra 1,300 each month
Oh I thought you said you had an extra
500 each
month that would be if I put into
retirement oh oh I see so if you put 800
into retirement you'd have 500 to go
towards the car okay and so what's your
current car
worth um roughly 6,000 because it's a 20
what do what do you want to spend on the
next
car I'm gonna need to spend at least 10
maybe 15 if I buy used which is the plan
okay so if you buy 15 and your current
one's worth six you need
nine right and that takes uh what say
see it takes not even a year well it
takes no it takes a little over year it
takes 14 15 months to save that up at
500 a month right exactly okay so 14 or
15 months you got your car upgrade
meanwhile you're putting 15% of your
income in and then we'll start paying
extra on the
house I'd only have 500 extra to go
towards theal if I I know but you you've
also you've extrapolated out into the
distant future no
raises that's true too yeah so it's a
miss so the reality is you're going to
pay off the house probably in six or
seven years while putting 15% away while
replacing this car with a decent thing
everything you've described to me is
very sane you are not a cray cray
American you're not out of control thank
you I mean really you you're you're very
levelheaded I mean you I I was a bit
afraid you were going to say $35,000 car
and I was going to have a small cow
right here on the radio Okay so no Mom
raised Mom and Dad raised this
differently from that I'm telling you so
you you really have your your
your your feet on the ground in a
beautiful way you got a lot of common
sense kiddo so you're going to be fine
yeah so the thing is this you're going
to accomplish everything the the way we
ran out the case studies and the way
we've talked to literally millions of
people that we've made into millionaires
is that this idea if you're putting 15%
away don't put more than that but don't
put less than that you're going to end
up a multi-millionaire with that alone
and you're going to get the house paid
off on average and your numbers are not
different than that uh you know under 10
years it might be seven it might be 6.5
and it depends on the curve on your
raise as well how quick you how much
your raise goes up and I'm curious what
you do for a living yeah I want to know
this yeah I work in marketing for a
small company I'm just wondering Alex if
you aren't thinking about the gig
economy freelance marketing after hours
to speed up this buy a new car fund I
would really be considering that if you
have the margin in your life with your
skill set in today's Marketplace uh
freelance work as a marketer that's what
I would be doing to get the car paid for
what kind of marketing you doing for
this small
company um like mostly website design
Flyers social
media helping them write content what I
love doing is like talking with
engineers and then getting them to speak
in English instead of
geek that's a full-time job uh it's also
extremely valuable you're a translator
in a digital economy um the uh so let me
sometimes and you tell me if I'm wrong
but sometimes when someone says I'm a
marketer at a small
company the small company part of the
phrase is code for I feel like I'm not
being paid what I could make somewhere
else yeah they're very fair but no that
wasn't what I
asked did you say that accidentally in
that statement yeah
like you make 70 but you think if you
moved over Yonder you might make
90 yeah yeah I'd be thinking about that
yeah yep and freelance I can't say that
enough yeah and and lots of freelance
stuff on the side because if you can do
digital translation from the digital
humans to the non-digital humans you
have a
skill how would you start tracking down
freelance things you got looked at
Fiverr but it's so many International
people that hard to find no not
International you just start looking in
your area uh you're just getting on the
Internet you're talking to people there
there is a lot of freelance work there's
a couple sites I don't want to endorse
them because I haven't done a ton of
research on other companies like your
company that cannot afford a full-time
marketer yeah uh would buy would would
pay for some side gig uh contractor work
to get the same exact same work done in
that situation um cuz we have a lot of
folks inside of our building that do
what you do their digital translators I
never called them that before today but
they that's what they do and so you get
on a squad with the digital teams and
then you have to learn to speak their
language and then we also have to learn
that the consumer you know what's the
consumer facing after we write this code
what's it look like how's it sound how's
it feel and that kind of stuff so yeah
that's exactly what you're doing and
that's a I'm telling you that's a very
valuable skill in the marketplace right
now I think you're worth more than
you're getting paid probably you need to
think about that you're an amazing it's
fun to talk to you you're amazing
very well done very well done you're
going to be very wealthy you don't have
have to worry if you keep keep using the
brain the way you're using your brain
right now you're going to be very
wealthy your your decision- making
skills your thought Paradigm is
excellent this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here open
phones at
88255 225 hey guys um we can use your
help if you want to help us out it
doesn't cost you a thing if you will
click subscribe or follow or whatever it
is on your podcast or your YouTube or
whatever and just let you know just sign
up it changes the algorithm moves the
show up in the rankings and causes other
people to know we're here it's a free
way you can say thank you to us and uh
so click follow click that and use the
share button and if there's not a share
button just share tell people tell
people or take take clip click a link
out and go okay hey I saw this you guys
got to start watching the show you got
you won't believe it you got to start
listening to the show you won't believe
it and uh cuz it's absolutely phenomenal
how how many of you are there thank you
uh the number of minutes being
downloaded is just
astronomical uh on the different uh
versions it's absolutely crazy and we
appreciate you thank you very much leave
the five-star review you know all those
kinds of things really help change the
algorithm of whether these different
Services push the show to the front and
and make it as a suggestion or not so
thank you Austin is in Milwaukee hi
Austin welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call it's a
pleasure speaking with you sure what's
up uh so I'll try to make it quick here
but I have a two-part question that kind
of revolves around my career that I was
hoping to get some answers or maybe
suggestions on what I could do as I've
been listening to you for quite some
time now and ever since I've been trying
to do everything right um but I seem to
back myself in a corner here with uh
work and any further work uh to Major my
income growth um and I'm so I'm 23 years
old and I'm truck driving for a career
I'm a regional over the road uh trucker
so not uh Coast to Coast or anything I
make about 62k base gross pay but after
all my overtime I gross roughly around
85k a year which is uh 5K a month after
taxes and uh Roth 401k contributions I
have no debt although I'm looking to
make more money because I feel like I'm
meant to do more and I love my career in
company I work for so switching
companies isn't something I'm really
looking to do even though certain
companies out there I could get starting
at 105k a year by trading more of my
time for money and staying on the road
longer which I know is a big battle
between making money and taking your
time the only problem with being a
trucker though is that I'm restricted on
how much I can work uh with a side gig
if I would or more so a side job as
legally you're only allowed to work 14
hours a day and a Max of 70 hours a week
but between each 70h hour work week you
need to be resting for 34 hours with no
pay even if it's a non-driving job um
and so the only solution I would have to
think about getting is
a under the rug pay uh cash pay job and
or do I just accept a fate and make an
extra 20K by switching companies while
looking to try to make more yeah so
what's more important to you is it is it
staying in the the driving position you
really love it and then having this time
that you have now or is making more
money what's more important because you
gave us the whole scenario but it comes
down to what is the biggest priority for
you yeah I mean I you know it it's it's
funny because I do enjoy my free time
but there's most weekends that uh I'm
either not doing something and I'm just
sitting there kind of uh not having
anything to do and then I feel like I
could be doing more well you can be so
here's what I don't understand so
forgive my ignorance is this the
regulation of the company saying hey
it's Federal Regulation it's a Federal
Regulation you're not allowed to drive
so he so you can't yeah but he can't did
I understand that you can't work you
can't do anything any outside work and
receive uh income because if it's
reported it's outside the Federal
Regulation is that what I'm
understanding I could during the week
but I'm not home during the week except
for one or two days got all right I'm
going that direction okay so legally we
can do something it's just during the
week so what is how many hours do you
have on a regular week where you're not
behind the wheel of a
car uh typically it's about well you got
48 during the weekends because we get
off weekends and then it's
typically uh about 12 to 20 throughout
the week all right so 12 to 20 hours is
what you can work with to do something
else because you said I feel like I'm
supposed to do more so we have to first
look at what inventory of time you have
to do other work now we've got 12 to 20
hours so now you start getting into well
what is it that I would do if I wasn't
in the truck
what would this different type of work
be I believe you've got those ideas I
don't think a guy like you calls and
doesn't have an idea to so what would
you do if you weren't limited to the
truck this other idea of work doing
something more what is
it well I've I guess I've always uh had
a had a not I I don't know if you call
it a dream but I've always uh wanted to
start my own business as I've had a
really good idea with it and I could
spend what's the business um uh it would
be
make a business uh with protein bars um
because I actually am a bodybuilder and
that's one struggle I found with a nut
allergy is there is not a single protein
bar on the market that uh doesn't
contain nuts or at least manufactured in
the same facility so let's make this big
dream let's bring it way down for a
second let's play with this 12 to 20
hours that's just if you were actually
working for somebody but you've got a
whole lot more time to be able to to
look into what would it look like to put
together a prototype bar that doesn't
have the nuts in it or whatever it is
that you've got figured out you can
figure out who's making these things how
many different companies Across the
Nation are putting together protein bars
just like a manufacturer in any other
business and now I start to research and
I figured out and I I figure out what
it's going to cost me who would make it
can I just sample it you've got all this
time even behind the wheel of a truck to
be listening to to maybe podcast about
how to come up with uh a strategy to
launch something like this there are
people that do this kind of stuff it's
free so you become an expert in what it
would take to launch a protein bar
that's it we start there because if this
is the dream then we're not going to
just launch into the protein bar
business there's a whole lot of work so
you're using all this time to become an
expert in what needs to happen then we
look at the finance piece what's that
going to cost and so now you've got a
plan here's what I would have to do
here's how much it's going to cost so
now you begin to save that money and you
go slow you don't risk a lot of money
you try it you test it this is a process
so I would be putting that desire to
play in very practical ways as I just
described and then over time you might
see yourself going all right I got to
take a different trucking job to make
more money to come up with an extra
20,000 to put into my first protein bar
and I've already got several local
stores that are willing to carry it I
don't have a ton of inventory which
means I don't have a ton of risk and I
begin to put it out there and I see does
this bar go somewhere maybe you look
into it enough where you go you know
what I'm going to transition from the
truck to actually working for a protein
supplement company because I can do that
I can work for them is this
entrepreneurial or is it an actual
professional path all of that will
become clear if you take your time and
use all that extra hours and energy to
dive into what is it going to take to do
this thing and that's that's how I do it
yeah you're the way you're describing
your situation is that uh there's only
two options doing what you're doing or
not doing what you're doing and um
because you're you're looking at it as
an All or Nothing instead of an
incremental by degree change and so what
I do is pan back and say okay I'm 23
when I'm 33 what do I want to be
doing what are then the then what must
be true that's not true today for me to
be able to do that a and then you start
making okay there's 32 steps to get
there over the next 10 year over the
next 10 years we'll start taking those
32 steps and that's what Kim was
describing the first steps of the 32
steps but you just Begin by degrees
moving in the right direction a little
bit at a time and that method of
thinking will uh cause you to be able to
move forward versus I I I'm stuck you're
not stuck you can do the little step
in the right direction right now that's
what Ken's describing for you this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for joining us in
the lobby of ramsy Solutions on the debt
free stage Joe and Emily are with us hey
guys how are you doing great doing good
good where do you guys
live uh just outside Madison Wisconsin
in a town called barou wow very cool
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off
$72,800 and we finished up at about 200
excellent cool what do you'all do for a
living I am the guy that everybody
curses when they try to get into those
plastic
packaging uh the plastic packaging guy
I'm the plastic packaging guy I'm that
guy oh okay are you talking like when
you get like a a box in the mail and you
can't even get it open with an xacto
knife yep that's that level that's me I
really do curse
you I felt so
good love it what do you do Emily I am a
Quality Systems engineer all right very
cool well you guys are doing well
congratulations what kind of debt was
the
72,000 it was a mix between credit cards
we had an
ATV um a HELOC loan that we did use for
some uh Home Improvements and uh a
school pledge for our church and finally
a land loan so during the height of
covid we went and purchased about 11
acres of course you did sure yeah I mean
we'd been looking for land for quite a
while and we just couldn't find anything
that we really really liked and then
this one just happened to pop up it's
like nope this is it we just knew it in
our bones this was it so what happened
14 and half months ago that changed
everything cuz you guys were kind of
normal you're just buying stuff on
credit right and then you looked up and
went this sucks we're not doing this
what happened well actually the story
goes back a little further um today is
actually our sixth wedding anniversary
oh congratulations and uh prior to us
getting married I was a single mom
living paycheck to paycheck and had
over7 ,000 in student
loans um when Joe and I got married um
he basically took a look at me and said
uh can we do the best we possibly can to
live on one income essentially and um
basically everything that I was bringing
in throw it at TH those student loans MH
and uh we got married um long story
short um struggled a lot with
contentment during that that time um
realizing that you know we were we did
have a good income but trying to live on
that one
paycheck and um I switched jobs in
2021 um
and the great resignation kind of turned
into I don't know I was kind of looking
at the great regret yeah and um just
trying to get through each day at work I
was listening to music uh streaming
music to get through my day and one day
I just happened to think you know I'll
turn a podcast on
instead um and I I call it that God
thing that must have happened I just
happened to turn on the ramsy show which
I wasn't very familiar with MH and I it
that's my best promotional item by the
way it just so happened that that I was
listening to an episode one day and it
was Ken Coleman and Dave Ramsey oh wow
and um you were talking about uh that
very thing that I was living with about
changing jobs and feeling like basically
you had wrecked your career by making
that change and I was really really in a
dark place at that time really really
hurting and um listening to
what the two of you were saying about um
you know
basically being a slave to the lender
and as soon as you get your debts paid
off you can go do and explore what
you're really passionate about yeah and
um I didn't know what the baby steps
were at that point but I heard something
about an FPU class and I I knew I needed
to get that career assessment first of
all because I I didn't know what I I
didn't know if I was doing the right
thing or the wrong thing at that point I
just I just needed needed some guidance
and so I wanted the that career
assessment I I needed to uh get out of
debt so you go home and tell Joe all
this and Joe's like okay awesome this is
what this is what I've been saying yeah
this is what I've been saying she had a
great big but now what happened was what
happened was Emily you got a reason
to do it all of a sudden the reason was
escaping the crappy job and the toxic
environment right so I got to get this
cleaned up so I don't have to come in
work I don't have to do this yeah it
changes everything very cool yeah it's a
great haai you got to have a big old
haai if you're going to do stuff you
have to have a reason to do it so all
right let's fast forward yeah so you're
on board right and and so you guys go
let's get after this when you got into
it was there a Moment In the Journey
where you hit that big moment momentum
where you really you both saw the Finish
Line we can do
this I think so I mean even when we
first started it was like Wow money we
we got money that we didn't know we had
mhm you know I'm not a budget guy I'm
not a guy that goes out just spends just
to spend but I'm not no no I don't I
really don't but I like I like you know
tools and stuff like that and if it's
something I can use around the house I
have no problem going out buying it but
so I wasn't crazy with that but going
down and doing the budget and sitting
down every month and we do this fast
there's money here yeah it was like
pulling teeth to get me to do it but
once I started seeing the money showing
up out of nowhere I like wow where did
all this come from so the budget reveals
yeah and there's the momentum cuz you
now have we can actually nail this
that's great there's a light at the end
of the tunnel that's not an oncoming
drain yeah and then it became fun
because it was wow we we're watching
these numbers just click off yeah I
guess like boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom here we go here we go here we go
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt
is I've been telling people look into
your
resources um as as far as side hustles
we had our little side hustles that we
did but we also found other resources um
we have friends that have a hobby farm
and we were able to assist them on that
farm
and it cut our grocery budget
significantly because we were able to
get the fresh fruits fresh vegetables
from the farm smart and um what Joe is
really good at canning and
preserving Mr package Pro here yeah y I
love it I love it way to go you guys how
does it feel it's amazing to be free for
the first time in six years and really
more than that it's it's amazing um we
had a family medical emergency just a
couple uh months ago with a family
member and to be able to step back and
say you know what we can do what we need
to at this moment and not have to worry
about um the money side of it was was
such a relief that's a big deal that's a
big deal way to go you guys we're proud
of you Heroes you're amazing man I just
they're kind of a little bit like
floating they're not quite touching the
pretty good that's pretty neat that's
pretty cool very cool and you brought
your daughter with you right what's her
name and age uh Reagan she's 13 all
right way to go all right so Reagan's
whole life has been changed too this is
pretty amazing hey we've got the uh live
and give box for you it's the baby steps
millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book and the Financial Peace
University membership Give It Away use
it however you want to do it it's our
way of saying thank you and our way of
saying congratulations well done very
well done Joe Emily and Reagan Madison
Wisconsin area 72,000 paid off in 14 12
months making 170 to 200 count it down
let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb free
yeah this is how it's done I love it man
what cool people this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
our scripture today Philippians 3:13 and
14 one thing I do forgetting what is
behind and straining toward what is
ahead I press on toward the goal to win
the prize for which God has called me
heavenward in Christ Jesus Benjamin
Franklin said the Constitution only
gives people the right to pursue
happiness you have to catch it yourself
boy is that relevant today man that's a
mouthful that's a mic drop I gotta love
it mic drop by old Ben Jeremy's With Us
Jeremy is in Tucson Arizona hi Jeremy
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you
thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help uh so quick question my son
youngest son got himself stuck into a
whole life
policy and of course I want to talk him
out of it get him to invest in something
else so I know the biggest Hook is he
can borrow against his
policy I know that with the 401K you'll
get
penalized which leads me to maybe mut
funds which I don't know a whole lot
about MH so I was wondering what's the
major difference between the
401K and a mutual fund that he may be
able to borrow against in the
future okay um how old is your son he's
23 okay all right
um well I I don't think
um I mean number one let's just let's
just ask the question why is he going to
listen to
you well I've had really good really
good relationship with him and the whole
reason he got himself stuck in here was
because I kept pushing for uh to invest
to save money to think about his future
the but but then he picked a bad way of
doing it right and when you say son this
is a dumb way of doing it it's not a
good investment program what does he say
oh I can borrow it that's his big hook
yes okay well no one ever got rich
borrowing their
Investments right they invest them and
they forget them completely against it
yeah borrowing against it is not is not
a method of wealth
building that's a method of selling
Insurance crappy insurance but it's not
a method of wealth building right and
that's what got him in he was actually
looking for health and disability and
death insurance is what is what where he
started looking and then they hooked him
on the whole life policy yeah so I mean
my my point is is that we can answer
your question a 401k is not an
investment it is how an investment is
treated for taxes typically inside of a
401k you're going to find mutual funds
so you have a mutual fund that's either
covered with a coat keeping it warm from
taxes and the coat is called a 401 K or
an IRA or a Roth IRA or it has no coat
and it's out in the cold and has taxed
but in both cases it's still a mutual
fund could be the exact same mutual fund
and um but wealthy people don't build
their investments in order to borrow
against
them and so if he wants to become
wealthy he's picked a really bad way of
doing it number one borrowing against it
number two he's picked a the probably
one of the the worst Financial products
alive
today and is the whole life policy
because it has a horrible rate of return
in the first three years that you pay
20x 20 times more for the same amount of
life insurance so you buy a $100,000
whole life policy you buy a $100,000
Term Policy if the $100,000 whole life
if policy is a $100 a month the hund the
$100,000 Term Policy is $5 a month
that's what research tells us so it's 20
times more expensive
$95 extra per
100 okay now where does that go it goes
into an investment called cash value and
so you and the cash value has no buildup
for the first two to three years they
keep 100% of your investment as
commissions the first three years you
have zeros on your cash value buildup
the first three years well well that
sucks and once you get past having a
really front-loaded horrible commission
off the front end and it finally starts
making money the average whole life
policy according to research averages
1.2% rate of return not going to get
rich on that either oh and then when you
finally get past all of that if you
actually build it up you can borrow and
pay them interest to use your
money so if you have a savings account
and you want to borrow and you want to
take money out of your savings account
you don't have to pay money you just
but with a whole life policy you want to
take money out you have to pay them
interest to use your money that you paid
20 times more to build up this thing
sucks oh and it's even worse than that
you finally build up inside your whole
$100,000 policy $20,000 worth of cash
value and then you screw around and die
which we all do oh guess what happens to
your 20,000 that you paid
$95 extra per month to build up after
getting past horrible rates of return
and no and no commit and no buildup at
all for the first three years because
they kept it all as a commission once
you finally get 20,000 in there and you
die they pay
$100,000 they keep your savings account
so if you had a savings account at the
bank and and or if I started pitching
you a savings account on Tik Tok and I
said hey here's your savings account the
first three years you put money in
nothing happens we keep it all after
that it makes one .2% and when you die
you lose your
money no one would put money in that
that's a whole life policy so nobody
ought to put money in a whole life
policy so you can just play this rant
back for your son Jeremy when it comes
out on the podcast and it'll answer it
question perfect it's exactly what I
would do and I'm not even I mean that's
exactly son watch this yeah this is just
don't do it don't do it you got son of
Jeremy you have been screwed by the life
insurance industry and they are very
good at their business of screwing
people it's unbelievable horrible
product let me tell you if you're poor
the way they get you is the pawn shops
the way they get you is the rent to own
the way they get you is the payday
lender the way they get you is lottery
tickets if you're middle class the way
they get you is they make you believe
you're going to get rich on airline
miles using your stupid credit card well
that's a dumb butt idea
the way they get you is they get you
into a whole life policy that's a dumb
butt idea the way they get you is they
go sophisticated rich people lease their
cars no they
don't no they don't it's a dumb butt
middle class thing to do so the whole
life policy is the is the payday lender
of the middle
class it's a signal that you intend to
be in the middle class to stay there the
rest of your life because you got
screwed by the insurance companies
and I got to tell you man if you don't
like that and you sell whole life you
need to actually learn how your product
works and then if you have integrity
you'll quit selling that
crap because there's only two types of
people that sell whole life the ones
that don't understand it and the ones
that are Crooks because if you
understand that crap and you sell it you
by definition are a crook because
anybody that would sell someone an
investment that the insurance company
keeps their money that they put in there
upon death and call that a good deal is
a crook
that's just bull okay it's just absolute
scam stuff it just pisses me off and
I'll tell you what the I whole life I
thought it had just about gone away and
freaking Tick Tock has revived whole
life Tick Tock of all things yeah I mean
PE listen people if your social media
sounds like a Tic Tac you you know
there's only one thing you should listen
to on Tik Tok and that's stuff we put
out but other than that it's awful it's
a baren landscape of morons that's great
it's crazy absolute nuts oh God and the
whole life stuff is all over it like
they just invented it yesterday yeah
it's the oldest Financial product ma'am
the financial planning Comm Community
completely abandoned this garbage 35
years ago no one sells whole life life
insurance except life insurance agents
no one in the financial planning
Community believes in it we've all been
looking at it going you got to be
kidding for
decades and now that stuff comes back on
Tic Tac it's unbelievable wow I got a
new idea out of this rant a new sponsor
blood pressure medicine for Dave when he
goes off on whole life this is fantastic
can't stand those people it's
unbelievable I think you made that
abundantly clear that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
Jesus hey it's Ken if you like what you
heard in this episode and want to know
more about getting started on the ramsy
baby steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramsy solutions.com and
click get
started